fch tout savoir et tout comprendre sur
l'énergie électrique c'est possible
grâce à electropolis le dernier né des
musées techniques de la ville de
mulhouse qui a ouvert ses portes en juin
dernier des musées techniques qui
pourraient d'ailleurs se regrouper pour
former une sorte de grand parc
d'attractions technologique oui s'agit
en somme de réaliser à mulhouse en
regroupant toutes les activités des
musées un espèce de grand parc
technologique européen tout comme l'on
défend d'ailleurs strasbourg capitale
des institutions européennes l'idée qui
a été énoncé par un architecte du parc
de la ville a été repris ces derniers
temps par jean marie bockel et jean
louis hoffet fait son chemin pour
l'instant nous n'en sommes pas là et le
musée électropolis de l'énergie se
développe lentement mais sûrement avec
en particulier l'acquisition récente
d'un surprenant hologramme sous-marin
présenté dans le cadre d'ailleurs d'une
exposition sur les images en trois
dimensions blandine quel rôle cheney
il est vrai que depuis son ouverture au
moins de juin dernier c'est surtout les
170 tonnes de la machine combiné des
usines dmc et que l'on visite en
priorité à electropolis et pourtant même
si l'histoire de l'électricité occupe
une place importante dans les vitrines
du musée de mulhouse les techniques de
pointe ainsi que leurs plus récentes
applications n'en sont pas oubliés pour
autant à preuve cet hologramme d'un
mètre carré de surface qui vient de
prendre place aux côtés de panneaux
explicatifs qui aide à comprendre les
différents aspects du laser il
représente un câble téléphonique dénudé
et posé dans un paysage sous marins les
hologrammes on va peut être en recherche
d'autres tout cas celui ci est une
superbe illustration de ce qu'on peut
faire en 1981 secte avec cette technique
et jusqu'où on peut aller dans la
réalité et par la suite nous allons
multiplier les exemples dans d'autres
techniques que ce soit des techniques
qui ont lieu à l'électricité
ou des applications électroniques
informatiques les plus pointues pour
montrer aux gens jusqu'où va les
possibilités de la technique en 1987 et
les années à venir un musée aussi
attaché donc à évoquer le passé qui a
représenté les technologies nouvelles
très prochainement des thèmes aussi
variés que le lot graphie et la musique
ou l'informatique seront traités à
electropolis dans le cadre de
démonstrations didactique voilà qui
laisse augurer bien des choses en tous
les cas en ce qui concerne la
réalisation d'un grand parc
technologique à mulhouse un projet sur
lequel se pencheront les conseillers
municipaux de la ville lors de leur
prochaine réunion